the Apple watch it's expected in April
the first completely new product from
Apple since the iPad but will the
SmartWatch be a breakthrough for the
company the world's most valuable
company in deedle I talked to the
potential about the potential of this
business with Piper Jaffray senior
research analyst Gene Munster it's going
to be relatively small versus the iPad
and think about these expectations
called 20 million units that's going to
be about half of kind of where the iPad
was in its first year and so I think
that modest expectations I think a lot
of consumers that we've surveyed our are
still debating what the true value of
the watch is and I think developers will
determine that over time yeah you know
that's what Tim Cook studies at the
Goldman Sachs conference and talked a
little bit about the experience of
people using the iWatch or the Apple
watch i should say in at apple
headquarters and saying there were some
unique things they noticed because so
many people are wearing them they're
like everyone's standing up at the same
moment in a meeting because it all been
sitting down for too long and things
like that but he suggested the apps will
make a difference and everyone's can
have a different favorite app exactly
the the roadmap here is similar would
happen with the phone the iPhone came
out it was marginally better we really
got it exciting for people as just as
developers built apps and really changed
your phone into a lot of different
things and that's going to be the
expectation with a watch to is the
developers are going to actually build
the true value and so from a consumer
today they're debating whether what's
the value is it's just basically the
same as your phone but as developers
really optimize the short verses long
look which is an important distinction
about this watch there can be new
experiences built on the watch that we
haven't seen yet it's up to those
developers to really drive demand for
the watch now we've reported that Apple
has people in Mexico meeting with the
Mexican government talking about what
the watch might mean for health and and
things that might need I don't know are
there things that will need government
approval around the world for this watch
to do potentially it depends on what the
apps are and one of the big areas of
focus obviously is around health as you
mentioned and ultimately is that some of
those are more infrastructure related
and more healthcare related more it
could be more government and policy
related and
there are some avenues where the watch
may need more some government
interaction if that's the case it
probably opens up a huge opportunity for
the watch that it would be used as more
kind of as a standard issued part of
health care system when you calculate
your watch number the you number of
units ship for the year what is the
number and how do you come up with that
number well right now it's a lot of
guesswork and what we've done is we've
gone back and we've done surveys over
the past year in the u.s. we've surveyed
about 10,000 people and ask their
interest level on that and compare that
to past surveys around the ipad and and
we've been able to build some demand
numbers that suggest somewhere between
10 and 15 million now we're starting to
get some build numbers out of Asia that
are suggesting it's 20 million and so it
kind of gets us in that range the
reality is is that this is a really
difficult one to predict because it's a
new category and I think there's a lot
of unknowns about which apps are going
to be out there and so I think that's
our starting point is somewhere between
10 and 20 million and then we'll just
kind of build from there I would think
the really hard part in your model is
the ASP the average selling price
because of the big big over the the
addition watch the 24 karat gold watch
what do you think the top of the line
Apple watch is going to go 4head retail
our best guess is somewhere between 1012
hundred dollars so it's going to be a
huge asp the asp we're using our model
right now is five hundred dollars they
start around 350 and so we're we're
expecting them to have this big number
like you said for the high and watch but
we're not expecting a lot of people to
purchase it but that's going to be one
of the the clear wild cards around the
impact of the model is what a ESPYs are
and for the most part these are just
guesses right now do you guess that it
might skew towards the hey look i just
bought the really expensive you know
top-of-the-line edition in the first six
months but later on it's more of a
mass-market product i think so i think
you're going to get that kind of early
adopters they're going to want some
better features and pay up for a little
bit more and then as we've seen with the
phone and the ipad over time is that
tensed as we get into more of the mass
market adoption
understandably that the ESPYs tend to
slide so you know wonder if we're
getting to a point where Apple's looking
at itself very differently as opposed to
a maker of a small called for products a
handful of products that are able to be
customized by the user in the way that
the user uses them to a world where
Apple sees itself like a burberry and
says we're going to have some very
high-end style leading things that
establish what our brand is for the
world and many different SKUs down the
line for very different kinds of use
cases that's a very difficult of company
it is and we've seen this slow
transition to what you just described as
a more of a wide selection type of a
company and just with the iphone going
from one SKU too many and ipad the same
in the watches they've already talked
about outlined and a goal of having many
different types of watches and so i
think that this company is very
different and the big difference here is
that they recognize that one size does
not fit all they want the platform to
fit everyone but in terms of how people
interact with that they're giving a lot
more options today than they did five
years ago well we hear about them
remodeling stores possibly putting in a
special private room of jewelry like
room for the watch does that tell you
something about how they're sort of
reestablishing what the brand of Apple
is I think they are continuing to push
this high-end this desirable brand two
years ago there is a big expectation
that Apple is going to drop the price of
the phone to be more successful in the
mass market and the mergy mark and they
didn't do that instead to your point is
they've really emphasized the high-end
and I think that their goal is to really
spend a lot of time and focus on that
high end and then but still offer some
lower price products kind of for the
masses where if you can't hit that high
end price product there's still an
offering that Apple has which by the way
is probably going to be equally as
profitable for Apple for you to buy